مجددا ااا اذهب الى سان فرانسيسكو تحديدا
من امام مقر شركه تويتر حيث يتواجد مراسل
العربيه حسين الطود منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى لمتابعه همم مجريات هذه الازمه
انصح التعبير حسين اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد من عندك اخر الاخبار اخر المعلومات
وكيف تتابع وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه هذا
الموضوع
الان هو هل سينجر تويتر مما يجري حاليا في
نحن الان امام المدخل الرئيسي للمؤسسه كما
يظهر خلفي هنا
حصل اجتماع البارحه بين لهم ماسك بين
العاملين عاملين
التفكير بشيء همم
الموظفين من من يوجدون البرمجه كتابه
انه يستطيعون فعل ذلك يجتمع معهم هذا ان
دل على شيء كما يقول بعد الخبراء هو يدل
على ان الرجل بدا يستشعر خطوره الموقف
خاصه مع اقتراب موعد كاس العالم غدا اليوم
الاحد وهو ما سياتي همم يتسبب بزياره
العديد من الزوار للموقع الان هناك من
يقول بان موقع بحجم تويتر هو رابع موقع
همم في العالم ياتيه زوار لا يمكن ان
يستمر بدون انقطاع اذا لم يكن هناك
مهندسون تقنيون يواجهون الهجمات
الالكترونيه
يقومون بالصيانه لمنع
اخطاء او اي انقطاع في البث او في همم
الانترنت هذا ما يتجعل انا ماسكو وفقا
العديدين من الاشخاص ان يلين بمواقفه
قليلا وطالب ايضا ببعض المهندسين ان ياتوا
الى هذا المركز ل- ليعملوا همم مع
زملائيما وقالوا ايضا بانه طلب من بعد
المهندسين في شركات اخرى مثل تسلم بان
ياتوا لكي يساعده على همم تدارك الموقف
خاصه الموضوع سنصير قليلا نقترب طبعا
حاولنا الدخول الى الى المركز الرجل الامن
هنا طلب منها عدم الدخول همم كما نرى
اليوم يوم السبت في الحقيقه ولكن الموظفون
ممنون ما عدا الاجتماع الذي حصل البارحه
كان بالطلب من الون ماسك نفسه وهمم واجتمع
مع مع
من التقنيين كما ذكرنا هؤلاء التقنيون
الان يحاول انهم ماسك الان يقرا على
العديد منهم بان يبقى في الشركه كما قلنا
هناك همم اختبار كبير لتوقعه متر سيكون
غدا همم مع بدايه كاس العالم همم تويتر في
خلال شهر يزور تقريبا سته سته همم مليار
ااا شخص ااا
في خلال شهر غدا سيكون اعداده هائله مع
بدايه كاس العالم لهذا السبب هناك همم
اصرار منهم ماسك على لا يخسر كل شيء كما
يقول البعد ولكن حتى الان هو همم يعني همم
يفعل ما يشاء كما يقول كما يقولون عنه
ولكن ربما يتغير سنسير هنا في في همم في
هذا الشارع هذا هو همم المبنى المؤلف طالب
من همم مبنيين كما ذكرنا سابقا همم
الوصل بينهما كما سنرى يعني مثلا بينهما
من خلال جسر ايضا اضافه همم الارضي همم هل
حسين هل من معلومات عن اجتماعات سيعقدها
لهم ماسك ما عدد من الموظفين او كبار
الموظفين همم في تويتر اليوم وفي سؤال من
احد المتابعين يعني الى متى ستظل ابواب
تويتر مقفله يعني هنا قيل انه اليوم
الاثنين ام لا هذا الامر سيمدد
طالب هو كان المفروض يوم الاثنين ولكن
راينا البارحه انه اجتمع مع عدد من
الاشخاص البارحه هو ارسل بريد الكتروني
الى عدد من الموظفين طلبهم كما قلنا طلبهم
بان ياتوا اذا كانوا يجدون البرمجه طلب
عدد من التقنيين بان يبقوا همم في وظائفهم
يبدو كما قلنا انه بدا يلين قليلا بسبب
تخوف من ان لا يستمر موقع تويتر كما هو
بمعنى ان يبقى همم
الوصول اليهم معنى التحديث تحديث التايم
لاين رفع وتنزيل الفيديوهات عن هذه كل
امور همم بدا لهم ماسك يشعر بانها همم
جديه وليست مساله سهله لهذا سبب حتى هناك
يقولون لا يمكن لاي موقع تواصل الاجتماعي
بحاجه تويتر او فيسبوك او انستغرام ان
يستمر بدون همم بدون كم كبير من المهندسين
همم الافرستراكشن البنيه التحتيه للمواقع
خاصه التي تعتمد في بعض منها على الحوسبه
الالكترونيه ايضا لذلك هم همم يتوقعون ان
يكون هناك اجتماعات همم الان همم يوم او
غدا ومن المحت- المحترم يكون هناك ايضا
كما قال البعض ان يكون هناك حلول وسطيه
ولكن همم لا ندري ان كان الموظفون هذه
المره هم من سيقبل همم
العوده لانه همم هناك همم يعني في هناك
اراء متضاربه هناك من يقول بان الشروط
التي يضعها لهم ماسك شروط تعجيزيه خاصه
انه قال همم او تحدث عن موضوع العمل عن
بعد ولكن ايضا ثم اعاده وغير قليلا هنا
همم اكثر من موقف مؤخرا يبدوا انها بدات
تتغير ولكن يبدو ان ان الامور يعني ربما
نشهد اليوم همم اجتماع اخر هنا في هذا
المبنى
لا ندري على وجه الدقه حتى الان نزلنا في
ساعات الصباح الاولى الساعه الثامنه صباحا
الاجتماع كان امبارح ليلا وغرد لهم ما
تقريبا قبل خمس ساعات فقط من همم من الان
عندما عرض الصوره صوره صوره اجتماعي معك
حسين نحن سنكون معك سنكون معك بطبيعه
الحال فوق الورود اي جديد خصوصا هذا
الموضوع لانه الموضوع الساعه من امام مقر
شركه تويتر في سان فرانسيسكو مراسل
العربيه حسين الطاووس شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المتابعه